la majorité des canadiens ont des
craintes qu'avec la légalisation du
cannabis
il ya plus de gens avec les facultés
affaiblies sur les routes donc plus
d'accidents on a vérifié
[Musique]
on a pris deux exemples aux états unis
où le pote est légal depuis 2014 le
colorado et l'état de washington en 2013
quand le cannabis n'avait pas été encore
légalisé au colorado dans 13 % des
accidents mortels
un des chauffeurs avait consommé une
fois légale que pourcentage a augmenté
d'année en année pour atteindre 22% en
d'ailleurs l'année dernière parmi tous
les accidents y en a eu trois ou les
chauffeurs des deux véhicules impliqués
avaient tous les deux consommé du
cannabis
dans l'état de washington on voit que
oui il y à une augmentation des
accidents mortels impliquant un
chauffeur qui avait pris du cannabis
mais seulement l'année où le pote est
devenu légal l'année suivante il ya eu
diminution
cannes cannabis relégables on n'aura
plus le droit de conduire avec les
facultés affaiblies sont un peu comme
l'alcool on peut en voir mais on n'a pas
le droit de conduire en état d'ébriété
le canada à l'intention de mettre la
limite à 2 nanogrammes de thc par
millilitre de ça c'est plus sévère qu'au
colorado que dans l'état de washington
où la limite est à 5 nanogrammes 5
nanogrammes soit c'est un toc ont
atteint en fumant une bouffée d'un joint
et ça prend quatre heures avant de
pouvoir continu
si vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque
chose écrivez nous
[Musique]